notre chef de bureau à québec est avec
nous c'est bastien on a beaucoup parlé
des dépenses indues de la lieutenante
gouverneure lise thibault est ce que les
choses ont changé depuis cette époque
oui après celle l'héritage de lise
thibault d'abord le budget du
lieutenant-gouverneur ce que des
québécois vers son budget de
fonctionnement lui un gouverneur a été
plafonné depuis plusieurs années environ
750 mille dollars et les dépenses du
lieutenant-gouverneur sont aussi
analysées de façon beaucoup plus serré
ce qui nous rappelle par ailleurs qu'à
l'époque devise thibault il y avait des
gens au gouvernement qu'ils approuvaient
ses comptes de dépenses alors oui les
thibault a fraudé les québécois willis
thibault a abusé de la confiance des
québécois mais au gouvernement il y a
des gens qui ont fait preuve de laxisme
à défaut de meilleur mot probablement
qu'on leur dise est pas trop poser de
questions sur les dépenses de l'esti
beau et en principe il y avait des
contrôles qui aurait dû allumer une
lumière rouge
sa peau était le cas à l'époque donc il
ya des leçons quand même qu'ils ont été
apprises de la sphère lise thibault il y
en a plusieurs qui remettent en question
la pertinence même de cette fonction
d'un lieutenant gouverneur oui à
commencer par le parti québécois qui a
boycotté la semaine dernière
l'assermentation du nouveau gouverneur j
michel doyon monsieur doyon dans une
entrevue à la presse canadienne a
insisté sur les pouvoirs exceptionnels
qu'il possède comme institution au
québec et d'ailleurs quand on lit les
listes c'est assez important et presque
renversant assermentation du premier
ministre assermentation de six ministres
nomination des juges dissolution de la
chambre
signature ou sanction des projets doit
d'ailleurs on va raconter qu'ils avaient
un lieutenant gouverneur dans les
soirées sans qui au moment d'apposer sa
signature sur les projets de loi pour
qu'ils entrent en vigueur
lever les yeux et dit aux gens autour
vous savez je pourrais ne pas signer les
projets doit donc empêcher leur entrée
en vigueur pour rappeler qu'il avait des
pouvoirs exceptionnels
en même temps c'est pouvoir là dans le
contexte actuel ils sont symboliques
ce serait impensable politiquement
indéfendable pour un lieutenant
gouverneur d'aller à l'encontre de
l'assemblée de la volonté de l'assemblée
nationale alors c'est la raison pour
laquelle il ya bien des gens qui pensent
que cette fonction-là n'a plus sa place
actuellement voilà merci sébastien
au revoir